[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau de tv 78
deuxième numéro de si on sortait
magazine pour vous accompagner pendant
cette période de confinement censé durer
jusqu'au début du mois de décembre le
salon histoire de lire 2020 de
versailles est à suivre cette année
depuis chez vous en ligne une semaine
complète de conférences de rencontres et
même de dédicaces qui débute le 16
novembre un jeu de société pour
découvrir les yvelines c'est le pari de
la société créée à comme guèye ce sont
non sire si nos modes d'emploi à suivre
et puis nous parlerons music edgar lourd
a peur des clayes-sous-bois nous
présentera ses derniers titres sa
carrière se poursuit depuis maintenant
13 ans
-a suivre également une sélection cinéma
autour de la première guerre mondiale et
puis des mangas qui mélange les genres
avec des zombies à la cour de louis saez
pour débuter c'est justin qui m'a
rejoint bonjour justin est bienvenu en
plateau vous allez nous présenter
aujourd'hui le nouveau titre nouveau
clip de galles où c'est un rappeur que
l'on voit juste derrière moi derrière
nous saint quentinois son nouveau
morceau s'appelle la classe ce sont les
enfants qui sont à l'honneur
exactement alors en fait les enfants
portent des noms de villes sur leur
t-shirt et puis pour chaque refrain on
entend par exemple marseille c'est la
classe lille c'est la classe et cetera
le but c'est de montrer en fait qu'en
france on a un métissage nos religions
nos couleurs de peau et même nos
cultures sont différents et galeries
explique que c'est cette différence qui
fait notre force
et ça c'est la classe là on gagne tout
de suite un extrait du clip avoir offert
aux personnes âgées la toile en mettant
en scène les enfants on s'éloigne un peu
de ce qui se fait classiquement dans le
milieu du rap
oui c'est ça en fait le but était
vraiment de faire une journée idéale
pour les enfants qui rêvent d'être
chanteur rappeur ou même star de
télévision est en fait l'équipe a pris
un peu tout les clichés durable donc
actuelle et les ont transformées pour
les réadapter à l'enfance par exemple
elle les voitures sont miniatures et
puis les billets eh bien ce sont des
milliers de monopoly les bonbons voilà
c'est comme si c'était c'était la drogue
ou c'était un passe droit pour rentrer
dans la soirée le champomy c'est le
champagne on voit dans tous les clips de
rap d'aidé et rappeur qui viennent avec
des bouteilles de champagne et où les
nerf l'énervent c'est les armes parce
qu'on voit beaucoup d'armes dans les
cultes europe et mon moi c'était pas mon
but de mettre des armes mais c'était
vraiment pour faire un clin d'oeil et
puis prendre un petit peu à contre pied
tout ça aussi alors gare à lou mène sa
carrière sur le département et même un
petit peu au-delà et il est issu de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des
clayes-sous-bois plus précisément et il
a voulu tourner dans les yvelines aussi
exactement le clip a été tourné à
plaisir justement les enfants étaient
très attentifs ans était d'après le
chanteur comme un peu une journée au
centre aéré
et puis les enfants se sont éclatés
gallo a même quelques anecdotes pour
nous on a commencé à mettre les bonbons
aller à les positionner pour pour faire
l'essai n'est en fait les petits ils ont
tous mangé en même pas dix minutes
donc du coup on a dû remettre des
bonbons voilà j'ai cette anecdote après
il ya plein d'anecdotes ans ils ont
cassé la piscine moment les ballons les
ans ou tous éclaté avant qu'on tourne
des scènes y applaudit voilà quoi c'est
des enfants quoi ce sont des enfants et
les enfants il vit noah 100% yvelinois
actuellement ils viennent avec quatre
coins du département donc des
clayes-sous-bois plaisir ou encore limay
et ils ont répondu en fait présent
ensuite un casting sur les réseaux
sociaux et ils sont assez fiers d'y
avoir participé puisque le clip a eu
vingt mille vues sur youtube et ce
morceau et puis les autres de cet
artiste local c'est à découvrir sur soi
sur sa page youtube notamment et ce sera
l'occasion d'écouter un peu de musique
en famille pendant ce week end
confiné notamment merci justin nous
continuons avec de la littérature le
salon histoire de l'ira versa et ne se
déroulera pas cette année sur un seul
week-end mais bien sur une semaine
entière en raison du confinement les
organisateurs ont refusé toute la
programmation il propose des rendez vous
en ligne est les amateurs d'histoire
avant dont pour voir suivre des
conférences mais aussi participer et
c'est inédit à des rencontres dédicaces
ce sera à partir du 16 novembre le sujet
des lots nord sinoquet depuis 12 ans pas
moins de vingt-cinq mille passionnés
d'histoire se rassemblent à versailles
le dernier week-end de novembre cette
année confinement oblige la 13e édition
du salon histoire de lire se fera en
visioconférence c'est pas parce que nous
sommes confinés voire même au contraire
c'est parce que nous sommes confinés
nous avons plus de temps libre pour pour
lire
voilà mais faut-il encore avoir accès
aux livres
donc voilà on facilite ce travail avec
ce salon hors du commun
au programme des live tous les soirs
pendant quinze jours avec les auteurs
invités du salon les visiteurs virtuels
pourront poser leurs questions en direct
sur youtube ou facebook
on attaque avec le général gomart qui va
nous raconter l'histoire des services
secrets
on enchaîne avec muriel gilbert qui va
nous parler de l'histoire de la route
française on va parler de de gaulle mais
aussi patrick poivre d'arvor alain juppé
ou encore raphaëlle bacqué les auteurs
seront nombreux pas de rencontre
physique mais les organisateurs ont
souhaité conserver la partie dédicaces
vous envoyez un message pendant le
direct et donc les auteurs que nous
recevrons dans le studio télé resteront
une heure après pour signer tous les
livres qui auraient été commandés et
tous ces livres seront click and collect
chez les libraires notamment la rivière
antoine de versailles un apéro d'auteur
pour remplacer les traditionnels cafés
est aussi prévue enfin autre événement
de cette 13e édition le prix du youtube
heures d'histoire mis en place il y a
trois ans à la place de la grande
cérémonie avec 500 jeunes en live
là aussi il y a donc 34 jeunes youtuber
qui ont concouru cette année c'est un
record absolu qui en a huit nominés il
faudra choisir tranchées qui est le
youtuber 2020 entièrement digital ce
rendez vous littéraire yvelinois durera
15 jours du 16 au 28 novembre
avis aux curieux confiné en reste dans
la littérature historique mais revisitée
cette fois-ci bonjour mélanie vous allez
nous parler de manga est également de
zombies les deux ne sont pas
incompatibles les yvelines c'est souvent
une source d'inspiration pour tous les
auteurs à travers le monde entier la
ville qui attire le plus en tout cas les
japonais c'est ça se voit souvent à
travers les mangas à leurs différentes
créations et c'est versailles mais cette
fois ci eh bien on va pas s'intéresser
comme par le passé en 73 il y avait déjà
eu un manga qui s'intéressent au mariage
de marie antoinette et au futur lui 16
et du futur louis saez l'a cette fois ci
une invasion de zombies bien très
particulière car ce manga est plutôt
fantaisistes voire horrifique alors
bienvenue
en 1770 marie-antoinette s'apprête à
passer la frontière entre l'autriche et
la france pour épouser le dauphin le
futur louis saez elles voyagent avec
albert c'est son frère jumeau qui lui
sert parfois de doublure mais sur le
chemin le convoi est attaqué je n'en dis
pas plus et je vous laisse découvrir la
bande annonce
un monde apocalyptique versailles off
the dead
c'est ça la france dans le manga et
petit à petit on va y de zombies des
personnages qui inspire entre la série
the walking dead qui est inspiré du
comic du même nom pour le wars ou alors
thriller de michael jackson
on va ne citer qu'eux alors dans le
premier tome de versailles off the dead
on les voit finalement assez peu
l'histoire s'installe et l'histoire avec
un grand h va être chamboulée avec l'
attaque du convoi albert le frère jumeau
de la future reine seul survivant va
décider de prendre la place de sa soeur
et que vous êtes resté sur votre faim
c'est un propos avec des zombies tout à
fait exactement si on prend avec
amusement à la réécriture de l'histoire
et de certains personnages parce qu'à la
fin on voit poindre un certain napoléon
on se demande quand même un peu ou
l'autre hills alors la mangaka kumiko
souhait canet veut aller on voit très
peu les zombies marie-antoinette n'est
pas celle qu'elle dit être alors bien
sûr c'est albert on le sait mais il ya
quelque chose encore derrière et c'est
peut-être là finalement que le manga
réussi son coup nous donner envie de
lire les tomes suivants pour savoir ce
que va devenir cette france du xviiie
siècle les tomes 2 et 3 sont des hommes
sont d'ores et déjà disponibles chez les
éditions kana
le quatrième est encore inédit en france
est le cinquième est attendu pour le
mois de décembre
mais au japon ça s'appelle versailles
off the dead merci mélanie on va quitter
la littérature à présent et on va
s'intéresser un jeu de société
[Musique]
et si on rentrait pour se retrouver en
famille autour d'un jeu de société 100%
yvelinois sur sino nous emmène parcourir
le département à la recherche forcément
dans trésors mode d'emploi avec cécilia
400 go faire découvrir le patrimoine des
yvelines tout en s'amusant c'est le
concept de la société familiale créée à
club games depuis le 1er novembre une
nouvelle édition yvelinoise de cire sino
le chasseur de trésor est disponible en
vente dans les magasins du département
thouaré guyancourt trappe ou encore
château ce sont 36 communes sur 262 qui
ont été retenus pour ce jeu on a demandé
au conseil départemental de choisir 12
ou grosses agglomérations 12 moyennes et
12 petits villages de manière à ce que
voilà chacun puisse identifier
ce matin là les créateurs de cire si
nous ont fait découvrir leurs jeux aux
enfants du centre aéré de maisons
laffitte
c'est un peu difficile d'être on est à
l'aise mais bon bain une pièce d'or et à
tout ce jeu de société est au prix de 24
euros 95 et se joue de deux à quatre
joueurs sur chinois pour vocation d'être
une chasse au trésor dans département
mais sans questions sans connaissance
particulière sans compétence
particulière
l'idée c'est vraiment de découvrir en
s'amusant et des six ans mais aussi de
faire plaisir à mamie donc d'être un jeu
intergénérationnel
le principe chaque commune à une carte
individuelle sur celle ci se trouvant
petit élément
cet élément est également sous forme de
pièces d'or cachés dans des coffres le
but
retrouvez ces pièces le plus vite
possible pour gagner la partie
pars toujours du principe que le dernier
de la classe les médias en difficulté à
l'école doit pouvoir battre le premier
de la classe
parce que je joue et ce à un moment où
on lui doit doit pas être en échec la
société créée à comme games est en train
d'élaborer un nouveau jeu de société sur
le patrimoine de la france qui sortira
pour noël 2021 avant de refermer déjà ce
numéro 2 si on rentrait carte blanche à
présent un professionnels du 7e art pour
redécouvrir le cinéma à la maison thème
imposé en cette semaine du 11 9
vambre date de l'armistice de 1918
première guerre mondiale
et bien c'est le comédien bernard pinet
de noisy le roi qui nous livre son choix
il est interrogé par mickey les limites
d'euros pour l'anniversaire de
l'armistice du 11 novembre
parmi les très nombreux films sur la
guerre de 14 18
j'ai choisi un film qui est considéré
comme l'un des chefs-d'oeuvre du cinéma
mondial
il s'agit de la grande illusion de jean
renoir avec dans les rôles principaux
trois grands acteurs de l'époque jean
gabin qui pour l'anecdote a fortement
soutenu le film qui a eu beaucoup de
problèmes à se monter pierre freiner on
aristocrate erich von stroheim en
militaires allemands psychorigide qui
porte une minerve
aucun combat dans ce film sur la guerre
qui dénonce le nationalisme et il
anticipe netease c'est une histoire
d'évasion ou sont confrontés un ouvrier
des militaires des aristocrates un
couturier fils de banquier juif un
acteur et un ingénieur la grande
illusion est un film d'hommes qui réunit
des personnages d'origine et de
conditions très diverses mais c'est
aussi un film d'amour entre un soldat
français et une paysanne allemande dans
son chef-d'oeuvre jean renoir expose la
richesse d'hommes emprisonné par la
guerre et la condition humaine où les
affinités et les différences de place
sociale ne résiste pas au besoin
intrinsèque d'amitié et de fraternité
le climat de ce film sans concession des
gages en permanence un réalisme puissant
est saisissant à la fin de la grande
illusion
jean gabin en parlant de la guerre dit
en espérant que ça sera la dernière et
marcel dalio lui répond mais tu te fais
des illusions le film sort en 1937 et
trois ans plus tard la deuxième guerre
mondiale éclate
cette émission est disponible en replay
et pour se jeter un petit avant goût de
ce qui nous attend la semaine prochaine
avec un extrait de la malice family sont
trois la maman
le papa et la fille ils viennent
d'andrésy du chantier il compose aussi
ensemble plus de détails la semaine
prochaine bbc la portez vous bien
[Musique]
de l'est
allez
[Musique]